it's time for the launching Chronister a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour or so you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of lon genes the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope mister william
bradford huie editor of the American
mercury and mr. Henry Hazlitt
contributing editor of Newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the honorable john s fine governor of
Pennsylvania the opinions expressed are
necessarily those of the speaker's
governor fine now that the conventions
are over do you think Governor
Stephenson's going to be a difficult man
for the Republicans to beat well I don't
think he's going to be difficult in a
sense which your question implies I
think you'll be a worthy opponent but I
certain the Democrats are going to be
defeated quite handily what do you think
governor Stevenson's chief strengths and
weaknesses are as a candidate well I
think his main weakness is that he has a
terrific burden to bear in the brand of
truman ism i am sure that he cannot get
away from that label which is impressed
upon him i am sure that he tried to do
it by being a reluctant candidate but
wasn't able to succeed in that respect
in as much as he was again adopted very
thoroughly by mr. Truman at the
convention is that your understanding of
why he appeared so reluctant sir it was
his effort to get away from the Truman
label I don't think there's any question
about it and do you think that
in the future now and that his strategy
will be to try to avoid being connected
with the with the president ministration
as much as possible I I think so I don't
think there's any question about that
with Truman tried to get away from
Truman ISM himself at the convention he
didn't insist upon the Civil Rights plat
for a plank in the platform containing a
condemnation of cloture filibuster the
plank doesn't even mention fe pc now
Truman could have insisted on that he
got his candidate in stevenson he could
have gotten this platform in its
completeness what do you think governor
that the civil rights issue would be a
very strong issue in this campaign I
think it's going to play a part in this
campaign they think some of the more
than liberals are going to insist on
sparks Minh Sparkman the vice
presidential candidate talking about
civil rights and I'm sure that many of
the northern minorities are disappointed
in the plank in the Democratic platform
well there isn't a great difference in
the platform of the two parties on that
issue is there no I think there was a
considerable evasion and equivocation
and compromised by both parties on that
subject however the Democratic Party in
the past has depended upon its appeal to
the minorities to keep them in power I
think that they have endeavoured
probably just a little too strenuously
to get the South in a good mood and in
so doing I think they're going to lose a
considerable segment of the northern
vote now as a political tactician sir
I'm you are and I'm interested in that
particular tactic now here 24 as you
pointed out the Democratic Party has
been successful by pretty generally
doing what young Franklin rose
out and Senator Lehmann have wanted it
to do this time hasn't it yeah I mean by
a rather blatant appealed to the
minority groups and this time even
though President Truman indicated that
he wanted to follow the same policies
when they got down to the convention
that was a retreat from that wasn't they
a disgraceful retreat i would say and i
like to use of the word blatant they did
go out there to chicago they made
considerable noise they forced through
the convention a a loyalty rule and then
after they got it they decided that
didn't want it in full and they began to
retreat and they attach to that loyalty
rule a proviso which gave some of those
southern delegations and out but the
southern delegations didn't take the out
they insisted on sticking firm to the
course with a result that well they had
to call truman in and truman helped
through sam rayburn to have that room
practically abrogated what do you think
some of these young turks as they were
called have been completely consistent
about a loyalty oath or a loyalty pledge
they have not been consistently they
retreated in confusion and it was a most
tragic disarray of retreating troops
that one could ever visualize some of
those same people object to a loyalty
oath don't they in the halls and outside
they and they were insisting on loyalty
pledge within the Democratic Party it is
a strange the ad a and the young turks
and most of the young turks are
radiators they insisted on the southern
delegations taking a loyalty affirmation
that they would support the nominee who
was not yet selected and that they
would have compliance with a platform
which was not yet formulated yet
although they insisted on such action
they themselves object to loyalty bills
being passed by legislators which insist
on public employees taken an oath to
their local state governments in the
United States government and of course
the United States government is a
century in 3 40 years old and we know
what its ideals and traditions are and
we know what the platform of America is
Liberty justice and equality yet they
objected to that they just don't make
sense appletini or coming back to the
future issues do you think that governor
Stephenson will emphasize the prosperity
issue very heavily well I think that
that's the issue which they are going to
emphasize probably to the exclusion of
most other issues but what will be the
republic and the answer to that well so
that the republican answer than that of
course is that the prosperity of the
country is more or less synthetic it's
fictitious it's based on a continuing
war economy today the dollar is worth
about one half of what it should be
worth that affects your insurance
policies it affects the man with a fixed
income it affects government bonds and
it affects pensions of particularly our
elderly people you see and I think that
the Republican Party has to meet that
issue head-on coming back to the
convention sir I believe that great deal
was said about steamrollers during the
republican convention did you see any
evidence of steam rollers or bossism and
the Democratic convention well i think
that the Democratic convention was the
most bossed convention that we've had in
the last generation or two with it was
entirely bossed the bosses were in
complete control from all the way
through you believe oh no question about
that after after the first night the
young turks were in control of first
night apparently but after that they
lost control and that was due to the
combination of the big city bosses in
Chicago Pittsburgh Philadelphia Detroit
and many other cities and they in
conjunction with the president just
control that convention and manipulated
manipulated the way they wanted to what
was the chief evidence that it was a
boss to convention as you see a governor
well the chief evidence was that speaker
speaker Rayburn who was the permanent
chairman spent almost an entire night
working diligently laborious Lee trying
to overrule his ruling failing his own
ruling against the Virginia delegation I
never saw such a pathetic and tragic
thing in my life now coming back to that
tactic that you referred to wear by
senator Sparkman was made vice
presidential nominee you're an expert of
course on Pennsylvania do you think that
Sparkman's being on the Democratic
ticket will make it easier to carry for
the Republicans to carry Pennsylvania
this year unquestionably you think that
the General Eisenhower will carry
Pennsylvania do you I feel most certain
about that and and you think that the
demon art is that this middle of the
road tactic and the tactic of putting
senator Sparkman on the ticket will help
I do I I don't think people generally
like to have a compromise with
principles but if there's any serious
for me do you think there's any serious
prospect governor of General Eisenhower
carrying the self no any part of the
South any important state in the south I
never considered that the Republicans
would
have much chance of carrying any of the
southern states if the Democrats had a
good candidate and I think they have a
good candidate in stevenson one who will
appeal to the south at least
sufficiently to prevent the Republicans
from carrying in in the southern states
as a final question governor fine you of
course whether got a lot of publicity as
a man who sat on the fence for some time
and then you jumped for General
Eisenhower and has anything happened
since then to make you regret that
action do you still think that
Eisenhower is the strong man and that he
will can win the election nothing has
happened to make me change my mind i can
say emphatically note of that i I think
that Eisenhower is going to make a
splendid candidate and they ought to win
well I'm sure that our audience very
much appreciate your views tonight sir
and thank you for being with us the
editorial board for this edition of the
lawn gene crow scope was mister william
bradford huie and mr. henry hazlitt our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
John as fine governor of Pennsylvania